ladies would you rather
would you rather date a very wealthy
multi-millionaire billionaire who takes
care of you you never have to work
you're living the good life you're in
the mansion you're driving you're eating
you're doing the best things that you
want in life you're shopping every time
the only problem is with this this guy
is gross he's not so good looking it's
not exactly someone you're attracted to
or
would you rather date the hottest
coolest sexiest most fun dude ever sex
great all that fun stuff but he's broke
his [ __ ] and he lives in his mom's
basement
those are your two options what would
you pick so it's rich but ugly or poor
but funny
no yes
rich and ugly yes or poor but sexy yes
i'd like to know what i mean there is a
guy a handful of uh hollywood woman that
uh picked the former
rich and ugly
davidson
most women i think
i think more than anything most women
pick rich and ugly yes
yes because women at the end of the day
they want to feel
protected they want to have security
they want to live a good life they don't
want to struggle
how i don't care how much you like a guy
if you're stuck living in
homies mom's basement
i'm not saying should we call nancy tran
see heard
anyway that's something that's a
question that i asked ladies i love
getting their response because if i ask
that exact same thing
to a guy yeah okay and i said gentlemen
would you rather
date a woman who's super successful and
wealthy and comes from a great family
and has tons of money and has yachts and
boats and does whatever you want the
problem is she's disgusting and gross
and sloppy and fat
okay
or
would you rather date a gorgeous girl
she's fun you love hanging out with her
and you just have a great time together
and she's beautiful and adorable and you
have great sex the problem is she's
broke and doesn't have a job well every
guy would be like just give me the hot
broke chick i'll figure it out
yeah yeah every guy you added something
else to that where he was uh hot and
broke but also like doesn't do anything
like doesn't do anything to try to
improve herself she's just got like
lounges oh exactly that's the thing it's
like okay she's cute she's fun to look
up she's not [ __ ] doing anything she
sits there like do something
like i'm i'm doing everything dude what
kind of part time at starbucks i'm not
doing something hot
oh hi i'm dope i'm dope i'm just sick
what do i do anyway these are questions
these are such hypothetical questions
but this is the hypergamy game we're
figuring it out we're cracking the code
pete davidson when you come on the show
we'll ask you these hard-hitting
questions um
ah
gorgeous and broke
what so uh rich and so go ahead answer
it for us
answer it for us well just based on my
track record and dating i've clearly
taken the young ugly hot
girl
okay
but then i wouldn't date a loser like i
wouldn't date like i would never work
like i would want my girlfriend wife to
work okay well that's that's the whole
question yeah i get it so
so you're saying rich and ugly then i
think at the end of the day you want to
be attracted to the person that you're
with
you know physically or like
mentally everything
right so i don't know i think i'd rather
get the hard-working ugly chick that
like i know at the end of the day like
when [ __ ] hits the fan like we got each
other then like hey babes yeah i get it
you're pretty but like we need to pay
rent talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken